do we have any content for today no
really let me do it hey guys
[Music]
hey guys this has been kind of a classic
Monday just a bunch of different
meetings and nothing too meaty for you
so
[Music]
so anyway I think that I think that we
can do cool cultural stuff like take a
break week where you work on different
stuff like just good stuff mix up a
great way for us to mix people so we
create little four-person teams that are
members that don't work together and
that creates culture right so there's
some there's some wheat like I would
probably pay to have four people like a
four person beta team like creative
account strategy paid for people to work
together for a week that don't work
together I probably pay to do that
because I think it'd be possible for a
five year macro for our business getting
paid for the weeks worth of work is a
good idea
a to be very frank I love that I love
that there's no like hard core obvious
thing that like they can make a an
episode around I love that time I love
that give me nothing because it's just
boring execution you know this is the
point of the vlog like the point is like
people think entrepreneurship or success
is the [ __ ] photo of you reco cello
or you want a private plane or you and
your boys or your girls like champagne
get up and like the reality is 99% of
successful entrepreneurship it's just
like you know axe to the tree like just
grinding like [ __ ] milk in the
[ __ ] cow [ __ ] milking the cow do
you understand
Thanks
overnight a check
[Music]
[Music]
that's okay
boss Fossum will be about um it's not
sexy it's not the thing that headlines
are written about it's not what I'm
going to put on my [ __ ] snapchat it's
just the truth like meeting after
meeting went up to a client in White
Plains come back here meeting meeting
meeting meeting meeting meeting meeting
um probably was like round I sent a
message I was just going through yeah oh
I saw her I was just [ __ ] like this
because it you know like this you know
and you know I'm a big believer
everything happens for a reason when it
does yeah if you just DM that person be
like Iraq awesome yeah
doesn't be like holy [ __ ] like like it
will open up [ __ ] all of a sudden yeah
when you do that and you do awesome ad
the Giants punt or whether they know you
or not
next thing you know couple months for
now they're donor they're gonna mean
with you yeah yeah you know what I mean
that's what I'm good at
yeah I'm good at looking at shin be like
okay it's all the off the field [ __ ]
yeah that's investing the money is your
life this lawn your foot will last this
long entrepreneur so you know do
everything do me a favor do me a favor
p.m. people yeah do me one favor like
take one piece of advice for me DM tense
every day but in the same way that you
[ __ ] practice for 3 hours 10 DMS 5 to
fans
hashtag punch our hashtag Giants yeah be
like yo thing right yeah and five to
just [ __ ] people that you want to get
like yeah right [ __ ] work like like
you should definitely do that
good alright keep me updated
Jim pleasure man yeah the star
absolutely cool man better tomorrow
come to bed remember actually like back
you know Camille each this is the best
part of this episode which is me looking
directly in the [ __ ] face and telling
you like great I understand what you
want I understand what it looks like
from afar with all the people that are
winning the truth is it's 99% of eating
[ __ ]
99% of milking cows 99% of ducking
action trees it's the non sexy [ __ ] that
is the foundation to successful
entrepreneurship what can I help you
with tell me everything
I don't know if you know this literally
there are like five ten five ten
thousand applicants for his job he's
like 30 jobs so it's like overwhelmingly
humbling how many people want in and so
it is there anything that I can answer
for you all right 7:30 I got two drinks
meetings right now one client one
without then Leventhal see of resi start
up we co-founded he's really the man
behind it all him and his team are
perilous guys anyway
we'll catch you up later a little bit of
them you might be able to learn later
but if not exist
just another grinder on a typical Monday
being an entrepreneur
[Music]
9:30 p.m. okay in tuna sushi business
dinner should get out of here around
11:30 another kind of classic 16-hour
day he heard my rant earlier nothing too
fancy had to productive meetings just
now I've done now with a very big idea
meeting I know babbles excited about so
lots of fun stuff I hope you're gliding
on your stuff appreciate your time
singing a lot about people allocating 12
15 20 30 47 minutes for the last episode
of people's time to my content very
flattered hope them bringing you the
value episode like this I may not say
something it may not I may not be a
detail like the DM business development
or some motivational quote in the
keynote but I really believe that this
episode is a perfect microcosm of like
the value of daily be like 98% of this
is like not going to be memorable but
it's um the body of work of 27 years of
watching somebody crying 15 hours a day
that's why the thing happened an
important lesson for everybody to think
shortcuts or systems or passive this
there's no passive there's no shortcut
it's [ __ ] hours and hours and hours of
grinding doing the right thing bringing
people value rinse and repeat
have talent have a strategy work hard
work smart day in and day out Monday
night 9:30 p.m.
what are you doing it on a Monday night
at 9:30 p.m. are you about to walk into
another two-hour meeting by the way if
your ambition doesn't speak to you
having to be in business meetings to
11:30 on weeknights then that's great
like everybody has different KPIs but
make sure your actions back up your
[ __ ] mouth
[Music]
[Music]